Watchmen is one of the most ambitious and
confusing new shows on TV.
Like, there’s these squids, an elephant,
and pigs, and a catapult throwin clones on
a moon, and there’s Lube Man, a meteor,
mind control, magic eggs, blue dongs, flashbacks
and twists, like what is going on? but there’re
also these serious heavy themes of trauma
and masks and race in America.
And the whole thing’s a sequel of sorts
to the original 1986 Watchmen, a comic book
about superheroes – the new Watchmen is
set thirty years later, and its timeline interconnects
with the original to reframe the story of
heroes in America.
So what happens in the new Watchmen, how does
it connect with the comic, and what does it
all mean?
Here’s the basic timeline in the comic.
The first masked hero was Hooded Justice,
in 1938.
He inspired the Minutemen, a group of heroes
in the 40s.
In 1960 came Dr. Manhattan, the only hero
with actual superpowers.
Manhattan won the Vietnam War, and Vietnam
became a state of America – Richard Nixon
stayed president for decades.
In 77, heroes were banned – only Manhattan
and the brutal Comedian could keep working
for the government.
In 1985, the main story begins.
Everyone fears nuclear war with Russia, and
the Comedian is murdered.
A weirdo called Rorschach investigates, along
with Dan aka Nite Owl, and Laurie, aka Silk
Spectre.
Adrian Veidt, a rich narcissistic genius,
attacks New York with a giant psychic squid
that looks like an alien, as a hoax to convince
the world to make peace.
And it works – the Cold War ends.
Dr. Manhattan kills Rorschach to keep the
hoax a secret.
Dan and Laurie fall in love.
Dr. Manhattan leaves Earth, and says “Nothing
ever ends” . That’s the original comic.
The new show continues the story in 2019,
and adds worldbuilding about the last thirty
years, partly on a website called Peteypedia.
So in the 90s, Veidt helped real-world actor
Robert Redford become President . Redford
introduced liberal policies like Redfordations,
which gives tax breaks to victims of racial
violence . In response, right-wing extremists
emerged, like the Seventh Kavalry – a group
of white supremacists wearing Rorschach’s
mask.
The Kavalry works with Cyclops, an offshoot
of the Klan.
Senator Keene, and Police Chief Crawford are
secretly Cyclops members, and in 2016, they
orchestrated an attack on police called White
Night.
A new law was a passed so police wear masks,
and Keene uses the conflict between the Kavalry
and cops to gain political power . In Episode
1, 2019, this guy Will kills Judd, and Angela
Laurie and Wade investigate.
Meanwhile, it turns out that Dr. Manhattan
is in Tulsa in human form as Cal.
Keene and Cyclops capture him and try to take
his power, then trillionaire Lady Trieu kills
Cyclops to take Manhattan for herself, but
then she’s killed by squids.
So like in the original comic, the main heroes
of the story are barely involved in ‘saving
the day’.
The point of Watchmen is exploring the lives
and perspectives of these characters.
So what are the stories of Veidt, Will, Angela,
Laurie, Wade and Manhattan?
Adrian Veidt was born super smart and ambitious
. He idolised Alexander the Great and the
Egyptian pharaohs , so he took the name Ozymandias,
and resolved to do great things . In the 50s,
he fought crime as a hero , but he realised
that punching criminals won’t save the world
– Veidt decided to prevent nuclear war . So
he quit being a superhero, and built a corporate
empire , becoming rich and famous off electric
cars, like an 80s Elon Musk.
In 85, he attacked New York with a squid to
end war.
Veidt achieves world peace – but he kills
three million people, leaving him feeling
alienated from humanity . The TV show continues
from there.
Veidt keeps raining squids from the sky, keeping
everyone scared to maintain world peace . Veidt
influences politics, getting Redford elected
in 92 . Veidt asks Redford to work with him
to build a “utopia” , but Redford doesn’t
listen . Veidt loses his influence and popularity
– he becomes “reclusive” , frustrated,
and irrelevant . In 2008, Lady Trieu turns
up and says she’s his daughter.
Cause turns out, back in 85, one of Veidt’s
staff, called Bian, stole a semen sample from
Veidt, impregnated herself, and gave birth
to Trieu.
Trieu asks for Veidt’s help and his money
for her plan to save the world by capturing
Dr. Manhattan.
But Veidt is too proud and stubborn, and rejects
his daughter . The next year, Dr. Manhattan
visits, and Veidt gives him a memory-blocking
device.
In return, Manhattan does a favour for Veidt.
Manhattan describes the world he’s created
on Europa, a “paradise” inhabited by the
kind and adoring Philips and Crookshanks.
Veidt feels so hopeless and defeated that
he asks Manhattan to teleport him there . So
Veidt lives on Europa for eight years, and
it sucks . Cause the Philips and Crookshanks
have no purpose , no doubt , no identity , no
sex , they’re boring – it’s like living
in The Sims, or in the Garden of Eden before
sin . So Veidt makes a plan to escape Europa
. Back in 08, Lady Trieu mentioned a probe
she was sending to photograph Europa, which
would arrive in 2013 . So Veidt spends four
years creating a message for the probe to
see.
He catapults Phillipses and Crookshankses
out of the bubble of life and onto the surface
of Europa to die, so he can use their corpses
to spell out the words “SAVE ME DAUGHTER”,
so that Trieu would see and save him.
The way Veidt uses the corpses of his servants
is a lot like the Black Freighter story from
the original comic.
In that story, a sailor is stuck on an island,
so he uses his friends’ corpses to build
a raft and sail home.
The comic compares Veidt’s feelings with
the sailor’s guilt and alienation.
Over the years, Veidt clashes with the Game
Warden, who tries to stop Veidt escaping.
But in the end, Veidt reveals that he wanted
the Warden to try to stop him . Veidt finally
kills the Warden with a horseshoe that Philips
tried to give him years ago . It seems like
this whole conflict was scripted – like
the play that Veidt writes, and like that
absurd trial where Crookshanks winks.
Was Veidt really struggling to escape, or
was this all theatre to keep himself busy
til he could leave?
Veidt needs drama and adversity to thrive
– and he doesn’t care if innocents die
for his pride . Trieu sees the message, and
sends a spaceship to rescue Veidt.
She freezes him in golden carbonite for the
journey – so Veidt looks like yellow yolk
within an egg-shaped ship – one of many
references to eggs this season.
Veidt arrives on Earth in about 2017 – this
meteor thing in a flashback is Veidt’s spaceship
landing.
But Trieu doesn’t unfreeze Veidt right away
– she’s still angry that her dad rejected
her.
So she keeps Veidt as a statue in her garden
for years – looking like one his action
figures, a monument to his vanity.
Trieu only thaws Veidt out in the season finale,
cause she wants him to see her plan succeed,
to prove she can win without him . But just
as Trieu is about to steal Manhattan’s godlike
powers, Veidt is teleported to his base, and
he sends a frozen squid shower to destroy
Trieu and half of Tulsa . So once again, Veidt
does something terrible to supposedly save
the world – he kills his own daughter, who
had rescued him from space, to prevent her
from getting Manhattan’s power . But this
time, he doesn’t get away with it.
Wade and Laurie arrest Veidt, so he’ll finally
be brought to justice for his squid attacks,
which sucks for him, but on the upside, he
might finally get that recognition and attention
he so wanted.
Ozymandias’ story is a warning that too
much vanity, ambition and pride can separate
you from humanity – as though marooned on
a distant moon.
Will’s story stretches a hundred years,
from the genesis of superheroes to the present.
Episode 1 starts in Tulsa, Oklahoma 1921,
with the Tulsa race riot.
This was a real historical event where a mob
of white people attacked a wealthy black community
– killing many people, and destroying the
neighbourhood.
Young Will loses his home and family, but
he escapes like baby Superman outta Krypton
. Later, Will comes to New York and becomes
a cop – but the police are corrupt, and
Will’s brutally attacked.
So Will becomes Hooded Justice, the first
hero in Watchmen – he saves a couple from
being mugged, just like in the comic.
But Will uses white makeup to hide his race,
fearing that white America wouldn’t accept
a black vigilante . So turns out, the first
superhero doesn’t wear a costume to look
cool – like he wears a mask to survive in
an unjust society, and the noose on his neck
is from his near-lynching.
He inspires the whole tradition of heroes
in Watchmen, but America thinks he’s a white
man, and never understands the real story
of Hooded Justice . Peteypedia compares this
to the iconic Western movie hero The Lone
Ranger – who, some speculate, may’ve been
inspired by the real-world black lawman Bass
Reeves . It’s an invitation to rethink the
biases in the stories America tells about
power violence and race . As in the comic,
Will has a relationship with Nelson Gardner,
aka Captain Metropolis, and joins his group,
the Minutemen – in the background here,
you can see Silhouette, Mothman, the Comedian
and the first Nite Owl.
Will uncovers a conspiracy by the Klan group
Cyclops to use mind control against black
people . Will asks Metropolis for help, but
he doesn’t wanna get involved – the Minutemen
just want publicity, some of which perpetuates
racism . Will is fighting to protect a society
that doesn’t protect him, so Will is angry
and frustrated, his wife and son leave him.
Will’s son eventually has a daughter named
Angela – so Will is Angela’s grandfather
. In 55, Will breaks up with Metropolis, quits
the police, and disappears . In 74, Metropolis
dies , and leaves all his money and his mansion
to Will . Metropolis says he was “wrong”
to not help Will, and says of all the Minutemen,
only Will was “fighting true evil” . In
2009, Dr. Manhattan visits.
Manhattan fell in love with Will’s granddaughter
Angela, and he knows that shit will go down,
so Manhattan suggests an “alliance” between
Will and Lady Trieu to take down Cyclops . So
in Episode 1, Will kills Cyclops member Judd
Crawford – using the same mind control tech
that Cyclops used back in New York.
Lady Trieu helps Will by grabbing him in a
car to so Angela can’t arrest him.
And in the finale, Trieu kills the leaders
of Cyclops, after reading a letter by Will
about their crimes.
So a hundred years after the Tulsa massacre,
and New York, Hooded Justice finally gets
“justice” . After a century of trauma
, Will can start to heal his wounds , and
to look to the future – he has a family
now, with Angela.
Will’s story is about the long legacy of
injustice, masks and pain in America, and
looks to the potential for justice and healing.
Angela was born in Vietnam in the 70s – lots
of African Americans moved there after Vietnam
became a state.
In 87, Angela’s parents were killed in an
attack.
She identified the culprit for the cops, and
got her first taste of justice from police
work.
She also idolised Sister Night, a badass movie
superhero . So Angela grew up an orphan and
became a cop in Vietnam . In 2009, she’s
alone, and empty, and grieving.
Then this blue MF turns up and says he’s
in love with her.
Dr. Manhattan experiences the future and past
all at once, so he’s in love with Angela
before he even meets her.
Manhattan says their love will end in tragedy,
but all love ends in tragedy, so they start
a relationship.
To hide the fact that Manhattan is a blue
all-powerful god, he takes the identity and
appearance of a dead guy called Cal.
After the random tragic death of her parents,
Angela finds it reassuring that Manhattan
knows the future.
But it can also be really annoying to have
a boyfriend who knows everything and fears
nothing – Manhattan’s previous girlfriends
complained of the same . So Manhattan decides
to become more like a normal human for Angela
. He gets Veidt to give him a device that
blocks his memory – Manhattan stops using
his powers because he doesn’t remember he
has them , he temporarily sacrifices his godhood
for Angela.
They get married, move to Tulsa, Angela joins
the police, and they start a life together
. But in 2016, the Seventh Kavalry attack
on White Night.
A gunman almost kills Angela, but a failsafe
in Manhattan’s memory block kicks in , and
he saves Angela by teleporting her attacker
away – that’s how Joe Keene finds out
that Manhattan is in Tulsa, and starts planning
to capture him . Dozens of police are killed
on White Night, including Angela’s police
partner Doyle . So Angela and Cal adopt Doyle’s
children – Topher, Rosie and Emma.
After White Night, Angela pretends to quit
the police and start a bakery . But secretly,
she takes the identity of Sister Night.
She hides her pain behind a mask , and fights
for justice . Judd and Jane Crawford make
friends with Angela and Cal, but only because
the Crawfords and Keene are planning to betray
and capture Manhattan – so the Crawfords
are incredibly cold and manipulative.
In 2019, Angela meets Will, and experiences
his memories , and learns that she’s part
of his legacy of survivors and fighters and
masks . Angela learns of the plot to capture
Manhattan, so she removes his memory device,
and fights to protect him.
Manhattan tells her that she can’t save
him, but she fights for him anyway, and Manhattan
says that’s why he loves her – her determination
and love in the face of the pain and adversity
she’s faced . In the end, Angela loses Manhattan,
just as she lost her parents.
But before he died, Manhattan said he could
put his powers in an egg, so that someone
else could get his powers . Angela eats Manhattan’s
egg, and tests to see if she can walk on water
– and the season ends.
So does Angela get Manhattan’s godlike powers?
Should she?
The season explores how power can be misused
– by Veidt, Keene, Trieu and by Manhattan
himself.
But maybe, after her experiences, Angela has
the right perspective to do some good.
Angela Abar was named after an old movie called
“Abar, the First Black Superman” – maybe
Angela Abar is the hero the world needs.
Or maybe Angela doesn’t want to be a hero
any more.
The ending’s ambiguous – it’s entirely
in your hands.
Dr. Manhattan was once an ordinary boy called
Jon.
In the 30s, he and his father fled Germany
for an English manor . Jon saw the Lord and
Lady of the manor having sex, and Jon stole
an apple.
This represents the Bible story of the forbidden
fruit with Adam and Eve.
The Lord and Lady give Jon a Bible, and describe
the story of Genesis, with God making the
world – they ask Jon to “create something
beautiful” . So fifty years later, Jon creates
life on Europa in the image of the Lord and
Lady and their manor – cause while Manhattan
is godlike, he’s not very original.
In the original Watchmen, Jon and his father
moved to New York, where his father was a
watchmaker.
Jon became a scientist, and in 1959 suffered
an accident that ripped his atoms apart.
But like a watchmaker, he reassembled himself
and returned as Dr. Manhattan.
In the TV show, Veidt writes a play called
The Watchmaker’s Son , which retells this
story of Manhattan’s genesis.
Manhattan won the Vietnam War for America
– which leads to Vietnamese nationalist
terrorism, including the attack that kills
Angela’s parents – so indirectly, Manhattan
causes Angela to be orphaned . Manhattan has
a relationship with Laurie, aka Silk Spectre
aka Agent Blake.
In 85, Manhattan goes to Mars , cause he’s
sick of humans and their BS.
But Laurie convinces Manhattan that human
life is special because of its improbability
– the “thermo-dynamic miracle” . At
the end of the comic, Manhattan leaves Earth
, to create life elsewhere.
So then in the show, Manhattan creates life
on Europa . He creates Philips and Crookshanks
to be better than the humans of Earth – to
be “Kind” and “gentle” beings in a
new “Garden of Eden” . But paradise gets
boring, and after twenty years, Manhattan
returns to Earth to meet his love Angela . Manhattan
visits Will and starts the alliance with Lady
Trieu to stop Cyclops.
Manhattan does this knowing it’ll lead to
his death , but Manhattan has experienced
the future, and he knows it’s inevitable
. Manhattan becomes Cal, blocks his memory,
and spends ten years with Angela , until Angela
makes him Manhattan again.
In the finale, Trieu destroys Manhattan, and
as he dies, Manhattan experiences every moment
he was with Angela all at once, and he dies
telling her he loves her . So the original
comic explored how superhuman powers can be
dehumanising – a god wouldn’t care about
people.
But Watchmen 2019 takes a different perspective
– exploring how Manhattan’s powers make
him more human, an infinite God of infinite
love.
He experiences past present and future all
at once, so he is forever an innocent child,
a dying scientist , a God, a husband and lover
all at once.
From his perspective outside time, not even
death can end his love – cause “Nothing
ever ends”.
The Bible stuff comes full circle as well,
cause Manhattan knowingly goes to his death,
sacrificing himself like Christ – only for
his power to be resurrected in Angela, walking
on water like Jesus.
So Manhattan was kind of useless in the original
comic – like Will says, “he could've done
more”.
Perhaps this sacrifice is the redemption of
a God.
If nothing else, dude hangs dong.
Laurie is the daughter of Sally Jupiter aka
Silk Spectre.
Sally raised Laurie to be the second Silk
Spectre, a glamourous sexy superhero “Just
like her mom” . Laurie hooked up with Dr.
Manhattan, and retired from being a hero . But
Manhattan’s a bad boyfriend, so Laurie leaves
him, and hooks up with Dan aka Nite Owl.
Laurie and Dan fail to stop Ozymandias’
plan, but they bond over rediscovering being
heroes together.
On Mars, Laurie finds out that her father
is the Comedian, the nihilistic brute who
once assaulted her mother – so Laurie is
devastated, and feels that her life is a cruel
meaningless “joke” . At the end of the
comic, Laurie goes off into the sunset with
Dan, planning to be heroes, but Laurie’s
attitude has changed – she wants a different
costume, with a mask and a gun – just like
the Comedian’s costume.
So in the new Watchmen, according to Peteypedia,
Laurie started calling herself “The Comedienne”
after her father . Laurie and Dan worked as
heroes for a while, but they broke up, because
Dan “wanted kids”, while Laurie “wanted
guns” . And Dan felt that Laurie was still
in love with Dr. Manhattan, so he made her
a giant blue dildo as a ‘literal F you’
. The dildo, by the way, is named Excalibur
. In the nineties, Laurie and Dan got arrested,
because heroes are still illegal . Dan refused
to cooperate with the cops, so he’s still
in jail – Laurie keeps an owl in a cage
as an ironic tribute to Nite Owl.
But Laurie made a deal with the cops to let
her free so long she works for the FBI’s
Anti-Vigilante Squad – so Laurie goes from
a hero to a hero hunter – we see her ruthlessly
gun a man down , and she takes her father’s
name, Blake – she embraced The Comedian’s
dark legacy.
Cause Laurie is hurt by her origins, and by
the feeling that Dr. Manhattan abandoned her
. So she hides the “trauma” behind a mask
of cynicism.
Like the Comedian, she calls everything a
“joke” , and laughs at the injustice and
absurdity of the world.
When she gets captured by Cyclops, she says
she doesn’t care about their evil plan,
that she’s tired of all the “silliness”
. But in the end, Laurie does care.
Cause Cyclops’ plan is to kill Laurie’s
ex, Dr. Manhattan, and when Laurie sees him,
she shows some real emotion for once . She
still loves Manhattan, or at least, is nostalgic
for a time when she felt love.
And later, Laurie sees Dan’s old airship
Archie, and she shows genuine awe and joy
again . It’s like Laurie’s ex-boyfriends
remind her of what it’s like to let down
the mask and feel something real.
So in the end, Laurie and Wade arrest Veidt.
For thirty years, Laurie kept the secret that
Veidt was behind the squid attack, but now
she changes her mind and decides to bring
some actual justice.
“People change” , she says.
“I'm not joking” , she says, cause now,
she’s not being the cynical Comedienne,
she’s doing something she actually believes
in to make the world better.
So it’s subtle, but Laurie’s story takes
her away from the cynicism of her father,
and towards some sincerity and hope.
Wade is a new character in Watchmen.
His story begins in 1985, the night of Veidt’s
squid attack.
Wade is a Jehovah’s Witness, evangelising
at a carnival, under the shadow of imminent
nuclear war . He meets some knot-tops – who
are like a punk subculture from the comic.
And a knot-top seduces him – which is a
challenge to Wade’s religious faith.
This temptation is a formative moment for
young Wade – like Jon taking the apple,
like biblical original sin, Wade tries grow
beyond innocence, but the girl betrays him.
As if that wasn’t enough humiliation, then
the world ends.
The squid hits New York, sending a psychic
shockwave that kills millions of people.
So this religious kid tries one time to get
his Watchtower wet, and the result is unimaginable
horror – Wade is scarred, and grows up to
be a damaged lonely person . His relationship
with an ex fails because he can’t trust
anyone , cause when he was vulnerable before,
he was shamed and traumatised.
He’s paranoid, hyper-vigilant for more squid
attacks, so he lives in a bunker and wears
a tinfoil hat . Wade runs a support group
for survivors, and says that he’s “no
longer afraid”, but that’s a lie – Wade
wears a mask to hide his pain.
After White Night, Wade became the hero Looking
Glass, an expert at interrogation, and detecting
deception , which are the exact skills that
could’ve helped him with the girl in 85.
In 2019, Wade goes out with a woman from his
support group – but she turns out to be
a Klansman who tricks Wade into capture . So
once again, when Wade is emotionally vulnerable
with someone, it just gets him another “kick
in the balls” . Wade finds out that the
85 squid attack, the catastrophe that broke
Wade, was a hoax by Adrian Veidt.
So Wade questions his whole life – “Is
anything true?” he asks . In the finale,
Wade goes deep into enemy territory, and faces
the man who caused his trauma , and Wade arrests
him, with a spanner.
Wade finally gets justice, and he takes off
his mask – the first steps towards healing.
So in some ways, Watchmen 2019 is cynical.
It’s about violence and trauma.
The utopian dreams of Adrian Veidt and Lady
Trieu fail.
Dr. Manhattan, the god figure, dies.
But the story also has hope.
Will achieves justice and healing after centuries
of injustice and pain.
Angela gets godlike power.
Manhattan becomes a figure of transcendent
love.
Laurie achieves some optimism, and Wade gets
justice.
We also got an entire season of Jeremy Irons
eating cake and playing with catapults.
So Watchmen 2019 isn’t about superheroes
conquering evil, but it is about some people
who find hope and healing despite the darkness.
The main symbol of the original Watchmen comic
is a bloody smiley, it appears all throughout
the comic.
Cause the bloody smiley represents how the
idea of a hero is broken, outdated, degraded.
But Watchmen 2019 uses the symbol of the egg
– eggs appear all throughout the show, the
season ends with an egg.
Cause the egg is the opposite of the cynical
bloody smiley.
Eggs represent rebirth, possibility, and life.
Thirty years after the original comic, this
new show brings hope to Watchmen.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video please like and
subscribe.
They take a lot of work to make, so you’re
welcome to support on Patreon for updates,
livestreams, votes and more.
Thanks to Patrons Rodney Gitzel, HASAN GOPALANI,
Mike Curry, James Butterworth, Veronica VanCleave-Seeley,
and Cydney Cohen.
Cheers.